and I'm very pleased to say that the
England cricketer and owner of the top
of rum Pub Stuart broad joins me now
Stuart good to see you this morning what
made you want to go into the pub sector
uh great question actually a great
friend friend of mine Harry Gurney uh
came to me years ago in 2016 and his
local pub had come up for sale and and
asked if I was interested you know we
talked in the change room a lot I was a
teammate at Nottinghamshire with him
about business and and that was
something that we really wanted to do
and it's we've evolved a huge amount
over that time it probably started as a
little bit of a hobby for myself and and
uh Harry definitely saw it as a a an
Avenue as a career after after playing
Cricket
um but the business plans evolved a huge
amount and and you know we're very clear
that we want to be a a growing business
now and and collecting a few different
pubs so along the way and delighted that
we're here at the tap and run having
been rebuilt after a devastating fire
um a year ago and and it looks
absolutely stunning so um yeah delighted
that we're we're back up and running
here it does look very nice from here
Stuart um I mean was there any doubt in
your yours and Harry's mind when the pub
burned down that you were going to have
to reopen it we attempted to walk away
yeah great question actually because I
remember so clearly it was during the
Trent Bridge test match and and Harry
called me at you know 5 30 in the
morning saying that the pub was on fire
which was obviously a huge shock and I
had to play the the rest of the Test
match so the day after I I came to the
site
um and it was devastating you know it
was a complete write-off really and
could only look through the windows
because if the damage took eight fire
engines to to put the blaze out and I
was I was quite emotional at seeing it
and my business partner Harry
um I was sort of quite interested to see
what his views were and he was so
positive straight away I bear in mind
this was two or three days after the
fire he had no doubts that he wanted to
to build it back bigger better you know
we've had amazing support from the local
community and ultimately when you when
you own local pubs that's what you're
doing it for you want it to be a
community for people to to enjoy each
other's time and meet different people
and um Harry was so so driven and so
positive about what we could do to make
the business is even better and and it's
come to fruition and it's just it's so
special being here and seeing
um the plans come come to place have you
know been open 10 days now and we've
been amazingly supportive not just by
the local community but but from people
traveling afar as well so no it was
there was a bit of doubt in my mind with
the emotions initially but but Harry
doubts those and and uh has been hugely
positive you mentioned you've got plans
to open a few more establishments I mean
one of the big challenges that all small
businesses have is is access to credit
do you think that's going to be a
problem for you down the line
yeah I mean one one line that Harry and
I always use is you know we we have to
be cautiously optimistic in this this
industry it's uh it's it's a fancy it's
a fantastic industry to be a part of and
and Harry runs it uh day to day and has
learned a huge amount over the over the
past few years particularly after
finishing playing Cricket
um but you know one thing that we love
about the industry of the people and I
think that's where it's so similar to to
sport is
um sport a lot of the time especially
playing a team sport is about the people
involved in the culture involved in it
and and the pub industry is exactly the
exactly the same as that
um you know I think it's quite difficult
to look too far ahead obviously we have
a business plan of how we'd like things
to go and grow the business whether
that's five pubs in the next five years
or ten in ten um but we sort of we need
to just see how the opening of of the
tap and run goes
um over the summer
um building up uh sort of finances and
and looking to the Future we've got a
pub um growthly in leicestershire called
the Griffin that's that's been doing
fantastically since December when we
took on so there's definitely a mindset
for growth but but we also have to to be
a little bit cautious in in the pace in
which we do that because ultimately you
don't want to ever put any quality in in
doubt and and it's important that we get
the quality spot on here before before
we look to to grow absolutely no well
you've got a week off or so before the
next test at Old Trafford um one thing
that's been raised I mean you've had a
fantastic Series so far top Wicket taker
but um England's Catchings left a bit to
be desired at times is there going to be
a real extra catching practice
[Laughter]
um yeah it's a it's a funny one you know
we've been we've been excellent over the
past year with with our catching we just
uh we've put a a couple of catches down
in the in this series unfortunately it
leads it it didn't hurt us too much
money to win a game and to be honest
having played in all three ashes test
matches so far it's it's been
breathtaking stuff it's been very
emotional to play in it's been very
tiring but it's um it's been incredible
Cricket you know I think every single
game the results could have gone either
way and and when Cricket is so close
like that you do start to look at
certain different things in your game
that you can that you can get right and
you know we know a couple of catches of
mistakes have probably hurt us uh in the
in the three test matches um but we've
got two to go you know two we need to
win both and and we feel really positive
about that catching is such an
interesting one for me and having played
a long time now it's almost the more you
talk about it the more you practice it
becomes a bit of a mental thing and and
you focus too much on it the key to
catch is staying very relaxed in the
shoulders and very relaxed in the hands
and things just happen naturally so I
don't think we'll talk about it much as
a team we just have huge faith in each
other's ability that when that chance
comes we'll take it but yeah it was
looking back to Sunday it was just
breathtaking stuff to be a part of my
nerves when I'm 37 years old but I don't
think I've ever been as nervous as I was
on Sunday afternoon
um so nice to get through that we've got
a few days off meet up in Manchester on
Saturday rest the bodies a little bit
and and
um you know it feels like there's a bit
of Ash's fever around the country at the
minute and we need to jump on that that
bandwagon and keep playing good Cricket
absolutely I mean it was great seeing
you getting in the Aussies faces at
Lords after the best or something
incident I mean that Gideon Hague the
Australian cricket writer wrote in the
times today that uh you know you're
you're the man that the Aussies love to
hate but he said he got gets the sense
you're actually the people that a few
Australians now might hate to love
[Laughter]
um I must admit yeah I um sometimes I
like to just get in a little battle for
myself I knew that I had it was such an
important moment of that game at Lords
and I need to make sure I was mentally
switched on and able to do a job for for
Ben Stokes at the other end so
um part of my strategy really was to
to pick a fight with a couple of
Australians to so I wouldn't be focusing
on too much technique I would just be
focusing on the ball and making sure I
could stay there so um yeah I mean part
of Ash's cricket and the the Rivalry the
history of it is is very much a great
battle out there and and both teams have
have been really stuck in this series
um but it has been you know a lot of the
players know each other very well
um there's a lot of sort of talking and
smiles we lunch in the same room you
know it's not as if there's there's a
huge huge battle going on um off the
pitch it's just you're playing for your
country I'd expect nothing less than
showing a huge amount of passion and
pride
um and you know just from being on there
on the field all the time the the energy
I'm feeling from the crowd and from the
supporters and from the cricket fans
around the country uh has been magical
so um you know we'll keep trying to
entertain and put on some brilliant
Cricket for people to love
um and keep letting us know that you're
enjoying it
we will indeed pleasure to talk to you
best of luck for Old Trafford and best
of luck with the tap and run too thank
you